Our scripture reading this morning is Luke 24, 13-35.
It is printed in your worship guide if you would like to read along.
Let's listen carefully for this is the Word of God.
That very day, two of them were going to a village named Amias,
about seven miles from Jerusalem,
and they were talking with each other about all these things that had happened.
While they were talking and discussing together, Jesus himself journeyed and went with them,
but their eyes were kept from recognizing him.
And he said to them,
what is this conversation that you are holding with each other as you walk?
And they stood looking sad.
Then one of them named Cleopas answered him,
are you the only visitor to Jerusalem who does not know the things that have happened here in these days?
And he said to him, what things?
And they said to him concerning Jesus of Nazareth, a man who was a prophet,
mighty indeed, and word before God and all the people.
And how our chief priests and rulers delivered him up to the condemned to death and crucified him.
But we had hoped that he was the one to redeem Israel.
Yes, and besides all this, it is now the third day.
Since these things happened, moreover, some women of our company amazed us.
They were at the tomb early in the morning, and when they did not find his body,
they came back saying that they had even seen a vision of angels who said that he was alive.
Some of those who were with us went to the tomb and found it just as the women had said.
But him they did not see.
And he said to them, oh foolish ones and slow of heart to believe all that the prophets have spoken.
Has it not necessary that the Christ should suffer these things and enter into his glory?
And in the beginning with Moses and the prophets, he interpreted to them in all scriptures the things concerning himself.
So they drew near to the village to which they were going.
He acted as if he were going farther.
But they urged him strongly saying, stay with us for it is toward evening and the day is now fast bent.
So he went to stay with them.
When he was at table with them, he took the bread and blessed and broke it and gave it to them.
And their eyes were opened and they recognized him and he vanished from the sight.
They said to each other, did our hearts not burn within us while he walked, while he talked to us on the road, while he opened us to the scriptures.
And they rose that same hour and returned to Jerusalem.
And they found the eleven and those who were with them gathered together saying, the Lord has risen indeed when has appeared to Simon.
Then they told what had happened on the road and how he was known to them in the breaking of the bread.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray together, shall we?
Lord, as you drew near to your disciples on that day, we pray that you would draw near to us.
Lord, I pray that you would open up the scriptures to us, that we might behold wonderful things there.
We pray this in Jesus' name. Amen.
Well, this past Wednesday, I'm sure many of us witnessed a remarkable journey that began.
I'm talking about Artemis 2. I don't know if you saw the space shuttle take off with its four-person crew.
The plan is for it to be a ten-day journey around the moon.
If they are successful, this will be the farthest that humans have ever traveled into space.
And actually on the way back, they could very well be the fastest humans who've ever traveled in history as well as they make their way back to Earth.
So I can't imagine what it must be like for them at the moment, wherever it is that they are at.
Well, this morning, I want us to go on a journey.
This text invites us on a journey that is far more exciting even than what is taking place right now with Artemis.
It may not seem all that amazing at the start. As we're looking at the very start of the passage, you've got two ordinary disciples.
One is called Cleopas. You've got, they're traveling down an ordinary road to a little place called Emmaus.
So we might wonder what is so extraordinary about what is going on in this passage in front of us.
Well, the extraordinary thing is not where they go but who it is who comes to them on their journey.
Because we're told in verse 15 that as they traveled down the road, Jesus himself drew near.
It's been three days since his crucifixion and they were certain that he was dead, but in actual fact as of that day, he was alive and well as he is still today.
But not only was he alive, he was right there with them.
Extraordinary.
And this passage is recorded for us here. Not that we just might know the fact about the resurrection, that Jesus really is risen from the dead.
This story is here that we might know the risen Christ himself.
So wherever you're at in your journey, whether you're a questioning skeptic or convinced believer or somewhere in between, I pray that you too would know this Christ who drew near to them.
And that we would all be able to join together, saying from our hearts, as we did at the start of the service, Christ is risen. He is risen indeed.
So as we join the disciples on this journey, we're going to look at three different things.
Simple things. One, we're going to look at how Jesus found them.
Secondly, we're going to look at what Jesus showed them.
And then lastly, I want us to see the way that it changed them.
So notice with me how Jesus found them there in those early verses, verses 13 to 24.
And by that, I don't mean like how Jesus found them, like as in like found out where they were at.
I mean, what was the state that Jesus found them in?
As we read here, we see that they were in a state of confusion, a state of disorientation and even grief.
When you get to verse 17, at the very end, you see that there is a visible, visceral sadness that you can see as the disciples are standing there.
So what's happened? And that's the very question that Jesus asks as he draws near.
So let's lay it aside for a second the fact that Jesus is talking to them and they don't recognize that it's Jesus.
But we'll return to that in just a moment.
But let's see, as Jesus draws near, he asks them what they were talking about and what happens.
And their answer gives us some insight as to why they are so discouraged.
First of all, they say, well, Mr. you must be the only person in Jerusalem who doesn't know what has taken place.
Another side note, this reminds us of the public nature of Jesus and his crucifixion.
This wasn't something that happened in secret somewhere. This was a very public event.
So that's why we can read about it in these eyewitness testimonies that we have in the Bible.
But it's also, you know, you can look at non-Christian sources as well.
Historians like Josephus, the Jewish historian or Tacitus, the Roman historian to see that it was known that Jesus really existed
and that he really died.
But Jesus draws their thoughts out further and says, what things, what happened?
So they told him about, well, we're talking about what happened to Jesus.
They talk about who Jesus is in verse 19.
He was a man from Nazareth, but he wasn't just any man.
He was a prophet. He was mighty both in the things that he said and the things that he did
and his teaching and in his miracles. He was mighty before God and before all the people.
So he was a man, but he wasn't an ordinary man. He was clearly a man of God and everyone could see his uniqueness.
Then let's talk about what happened to him when you get to verse 20. This has really thrown them.
They talk about how their leaders, the religious authorities of the day, had him executed, condemned to death, crucified.
And they had hopes that he was going to redeem Israel, but this dashed their hope.
By the way, when it talks about redeeming Israel here, this is Exodus language.
For those of you who've been here recently, we've been going through the book of Exodus together.
So here's their hope. They're hoping that this Jesus is like Moses, this mighty prophet.
They're hoping that God is going to use him like he used Moses.
Remember, Moses, God used him to lead God's people out of slavery in Egypt and onto the promised land.
And here's the hope. They're under Roman occupation.
They're hoping Jesus is going to deliver them from that.
He's going to bring them out of that. And he's going to establish God's eternal kingdom in that way.
And so they're hoping in that, but now he's gone.
Back in 1986, there was another shuttle that took off the Challenger.
Now that was a really sad occasion because he had so many people who were excited about the day
and they all gathered together, many children gathered as well because he had a teacher who was going to go up in space.
She was the first teacher who was going to do that.
And so everybody was watching on as it shot off into space.
Only seconds later, they then watched it as it disintegrated in the sky and made its way back down.
Imagine the shock.
Imagine the shock of Jesus' disciples here.
Just a few days ago, I mean, things were really looking up.
They were on the journey to Jerusalem.
Even last Sunday, we saw that they were cheering.
They were shouting Hosanna as their king rode into Jerusalem.
Hope was alive and well.
But now it's a journey, not to Jerusalem, but from Jerusalem.
Things are very different.
See, not only was the king crucified, their hope was dying with him.
Sure, some of their number, they say, were claiming that the tomb was empty.
They'd heard from some of the women saying that they had seen angels,
but they describe it here as a vision of angels.
It didn't seem plausible to say the least.
You can hear the doubt and what the disciples say here.
I want you to notice that they speak about hope in the past tense there in verse 21.
We had hoped.
They're speaking about Jesus in the past tense and hope in the past tense as well.
I'm sure we all know what it's like to live with hope in the past tense.
What do you think for a second?
Maybe you had a vision for your life and what it would look like by now.
It would be a vision for marriage and your children and how that would be or maybe a career.
We can name any number of things because we think about the future.
We've got this vision for what we want our lives to be.
And if you're a believer, you think, well, and I've got Jesus as well.
And surely he is the one who's going to fulfill this vision that I have for my life.
But then you find that things aren't exactly as you hoped they would be.
Your hope is now past tense.
It is no longer, I hope it is, I had hoped.
And maybe in the sadness of that, your vision of Jesus is even clouded by that fog.
You wanted him to take you there.
What does that say about him?
The thing that we need to see here in the passage is that right in the middle of the disciples' discouragement.
Jesus draws near.
You see, we don't see or rather they don't see Jesus, but he is there.
So what does Jesus do in their discouragement?
He draws near.
And this is exactly what he does with us.
We may not know what he is doing, but we can know that he is with us by faith.
So Psalm 34, verse 18 says the Lord draws near to the brokenhearted.
And he saves those who are crushed in spirit.
So let me say this morning, whether your hope for your life feels alive or it feels dead,
whether you sense the Lord's presence or not, he is near.
He draws near.
He is here.
And this is just as true in the dark as it is in the light.
He is present.
He draws near to the brokenhearted.
So what does he do for them when he draws near to them in their discouragement?
Let's see verses 25 to 31.
Here we see that Jesus steps into the darkness.
Yes, he is near, but he also gives them a light to guide their path.
He renews their hope by way of revelation.
And what does he reveal?
He makes himself known to them.
The thing that they need to see is him.
And this is what he reveals to them.
This is what he shows them himself.
And he does this in a way that you might not expect.
I mean, you might think, well, if that was me, I would have said, well, surprise, it's me, Jesus, I'm here.
He would have just come right out and said who he was.
I've risen from the dead just like I told you I was.
But that's not how Jesus makes himself known.
How does he do it?
When you get to verse 25, you see that he opens the scriptures to them.
He says, oh foolish ones and slow of heart to believe all that the prophets have spoken.
Now that might feel abrupt.
Foolish ones, slow of heart, but know that he is saying this to them in love.
And he is speaking in a way that is direct, in a way that kind of cuts right through the fog
and brings them to a place of clarity in the midst of their confusion.
He says, listen, this is what you need to hear.
And he brings them to the Word of God.
He says, I'm going to tell you about all that the prophets have spoken.
This is where you're going to see what you need to see.
So let's continue.
Was it not necessary that the Christ should suffer these things and enter into his glory?
He says, as we look at the scriptures, we're going to see that my death was all part of God's plan.
This was planned all along, even if it wasn't part of your plan.
A couple of weeks ago, our family, we traveled down to Gulf Shores together.
And it wasn't the first time that we've done this, but I just know that Gulf Shores is in Alabama
and you travel kind of straight down to it.
So I'm driving down the road and we've got music playing, having a great time.
And as I'm driving down the road, all of a sudden we pass this sign,
welcome to Florida.
And I absolutely panicked.
So I jerked the car over and pulled out the map.
And thankfully, for whatever reason, I'd been taken on a slightly different route to normal.
That did pass through Florida, but I was right on track unbeknownst to me.
Just being taken in a different direction than I thought.
Why is the disciples having been following Jesus?
They've got this shock.
This is not how they had planned it.
This is not what they thought would happen.
But nonetheless, this movement that they were part of was not lost.
It was just being brought about in a different way to how they had anticipated.
Jesus' death was not an unfortunate turn of events.
Notice that word that he uses.
It was necessary.
It was an essential part of God's plan to redeem the world.
Now, while this plan wasn't something that they had anticipated,
God had already revealed it in his word.
So he goes on beginning with Moses and all the prophets were told that he interpreted to them and the scriptures and all the scriptures, the things concerning himself.
I've heard some wonderful Bible teaching in my life.
But if I could go and sit on any sermon, this is the one I would want to be in to have Jesus himself right along beside me, explaining the scriptures.
And I would imagine being there with them and makes you wonder where he took them as he was opening the scriptures, telling them the things about himself and his suffering, his death.
Maybe he told them about the prophecies that would be fulfilled.
We're told that he began with Moses.
So Moses is responsible for those first five books of the Bible.
So maybe he took them to Genesis 315, which spoke about the coming Christ as being the one who would conquer the serpents.
So he was going to suffer because of that serpent, but he was going to crush that serpent.
Or maybe he took them to the prophets like Isaiah and Isaiah 53, where the coming Christ is presented as the suffering serpents, the one who was going to bear our iniquities,
the one who was going to be wounded for our transgressions.
Or maybe he took them to some of the types that were there in the Old Testament, some of those pictures that point to the coming of Christ.
Maybe he talked to them about the Passover lamb and how when God sees the blood of the atoning sacrifice of Jesus, his judgment passes over us just like his judgment passed over the Israelites in Egypt.
Maybe he talked to them about the temple where God's presence and glory dwelt among his people and said,
well, that was pointing to me because I am God's presence with you.
His glory is what I am here to make known.
Well, it certainly seems that he talked them through the storyline of Scripture because he talked to them about all the Scriptures.
Now they had a very short journey, so he had to be brief with them.
Maybe talk to them about creation and how God made us for himself with a view to dwelling with us in perfect fellowship forever.
Then of course there was the fall where we sinned against God and we rejected him and through sin, corruption and death came into the world.
And worst of all, we were separated from God because of our sin.
That relationship was broken.
But God revealed that he had a plan of redemption that he was going to deal with our sin through sending this Messiah who would suffer and die in our place.
Surely he pointed them as well to promises of restoration when one day we would dwell with God forever and we would feast with him in the new creation.
I don't know exactly how he explained it, but I do know this, that he showed them that all of the Scriptures, all of it was pointing to him because he is our ultimate hope.
In the Scriptures he is presented to us as the crucified and risen king who restores us to God and reigns over all things and welcomes all who will call upon him by faith.
So we open the Scriptures to them because the Scriptures point them to Jesus and show who he is.
But he also broke bread with them. When you come to verse 28, you see that when they arrived they invited Jesus to stay with them and to share a meal together which he agreed to.
And as they sat at the table together, they deferred to this curious stranger to do the honor of breaking and our blessing rather and breaking the bread that was before them.
By the way, meals are a major part in the Gospel of Luke if you look through that. It's amazing. Jesus is constantly eating with people.
And it's a wonderful way to do ministry, to share meals and life together.
And there are times when it speaks about Jesus in these meals, blessing and breaking bread.
So you go for example to the feeding of the 5,000. He blesses and he breaks the bread. God miraculously feeds the 5,000. He does.
You look at the Last Supper before Jesus' death. We're told that he gathered with his disciples and he took bread and when he had given thanks he broke it and said, this is my body which is broken for you.
So this is about more than food when Jesus breaks bread with people.
This is the living embodiment of the very thing that Jesus came to bring about.
When Jesus was sharing these meals with people, it was God himself dwelling with humanity.
This was a picture of what was to come for all of God's people.
And then when Jesus broke this bread before them, we're told that suddenly they recognized who he was.
Then he vanished from their sight.
See previously we're told in the passage that their eyes were kept from recognizing Jesus, but now they see him.
This is a supernatural work.
We can infer from this passage, but also the rest of scripture that God is the one who opened their eyes that they might see Jesus for who he truly is.
Not with their physical eyes, but with the very eyes of their hearts. Yes they saw him with their physical eyes, but their hearts saw and knew who he was.
So let me ask a question. Why was Jesus made known to them in this way?
Why didn't he just tell them, this is who I am?
Two things. One is that they might truly know who he is.
If he had just immediately told them that he's Jesus, he's risen from the dead, they would have had relief, but they wouldn't have had true understanding.
He wanted them to know that he was alive, yes, but he wanted them to understand who he truly was and what he came to do.
And how essential he and his work was for God's plan.
He wanted them to see what had been brought about through him, through his death and through his resurrection.
He wanted to teach them through his word because they needed to continue to trust in his word throughout their lives.
But this wasn't just true of them, it would be true of the people they would teach.
So here's another reason why Jesus made himself known to them in this way.
It's because that's how we all come to know Jesus.
At the beginning I said that this same Jesus who drew near to them draws near to us.
And you might very well think, well yeah, if Jesus physically walked up to me then I would believe, sure.
But here we see that that's not how this works.
And the fact is there were plenty of people who saw Jesus with their physical eyes and still rejected him.
Here we see that Jesus made himself known to them in the Scriptures first because that is where he makes himself known to us.
So this revelation that they saw with God's help we can see today as well.
It's in the Scriptures that we can see Jesus.
So one passage, 2 Timothy chapter 3 were told there that it's the Scriptures that make us wise to salvation through faith in Christ Jesus.
And here's how we come to see Jesus in the Scriptures.
Just like God opened their eyes, he opens our eyes so that we might see Jesus.
That's how unbelievers are turned into believers because God opens their eyes to see Jesus.
So Acts chapter 16 were told that the Lord opened the heart of a woman called Lydia so that she might hear and believe the Gospel.
But you know, this is also how believers experience the reality of the risen Jesus too.
In Ephesians 1 the apostle Paul prayed that God would enlighten the eyes of our hearts that we might know Jesus more
and the hope that we have in him.
So yes, God opens our eyes to believe in Jesus but there is always more to discover about him.
We need to live in the reality of his risen life.
And it's God who enables us to do this.
And yet, that's not to say that we should just sit around waiting for that to happen.
I'm just waiting for God to open my eyes to show me more.
If God reveals himself in Scripture, if this is the place where we can come to see and know the risen Christ,
then we ought to run to the Scriptures that we might see him and find the hope that is found in him.
We ought to be praying, Lord, help me to see more of you here than I've ever seen.
We should pray this for ourselves and pray this for others.
This is how Jesus has made known to us.
He's the hope that we need.
We think about our vision for other things and maybe things not working out.
What we need to see is Jesus and the greater thing that he is bringing about and how we can trust him.
And the place we see him is in the Scriptures.
Very briefly, the last thing I want us to see, thirdly, was the way that it changed these disciples.
First, we see that it changed them on the inside.
I mean, we saw shock on their faces at the start, but there's shock now, but this is in a different way.
The kind of sullen faces are now shocked that they have seen Jesus.
I mean, they have been on quite the roller coaster.
So listen to what they say in verse 32.
Didn't our hearts burn within us while he talked with us on the road, while he opened to us the Scriptures?
I mean, this was amazing what they had seen.
And they knew that something was changing in them before they had even realized that this was Jesus who was speaking to them.
Something was stirring in their hearts as Jesus was opening up the Scriptures to them and showing them his glory there.
The embers of their hearts that were dying out were now being fanned into flame.
You see, Jesus brings about an internal change as we begin to see who he truly is.
And this is a change of mind and it is also a change of heart.
We see and understand what the Scripture says, but then it teaches us to put our faith in him.
So God then takes these glorious truths of the Scriptures about Jesus and uses them in our lives to teach us to trust again, to rejoice again,
and to hope again because our hope is in Jesus.
And that burning that takes place in their hearts, notice, it now starts to come through.
What's happening on the inside now comes through on the outside.
You know, after the burning to think about the space shovel again, after the burning then comes the lift off, right?
So you've got these burning hearts, but that burning heart is soon heard by a speaking mouth and running feet.
Verse 32, they immediately start to talk to each other about what it is that they've heard and what it is they've seen.
And then it hits them that they've got to go back and tell the other disciples that Jesus is alive.
And remember, this is getting near the end of the day.
We're giving that little detail as they talked with Jesus.
By the time they got to Emmaus, they were seven miles away from Jerusalem.
And those roads were dark and dangerous at night, but that did not hold them back.
They had good news to share that they could not hold in.
So they ran back to the disciples declaring that Jesus is alive.
They don't waste any time getting back to Jerusalem.
They return in the same hour, we're told.
When they found those disciples, they joined together with them celebrating the resurrection of Jesus,
saying, as we said at the start of the service, verse 34, the Lord is risen in deed.
The fact is when the risen Christ draws near to you in your discouragement,
and he starts to stir your heart and show you more of himself,
the way that comes through is a desire to confess that he is Lord,
to praise him with your mouth, to speak about him to others.
Your heart overflows in your words. That desire is there.
It gives you a desire to be in the company of those who are also celebrating and hoping in his resurrection.
So that is why we're here today, because Jesus is alive.
And we want to express that in our praise to him, but we want to do that together because he is worthy.
You see, this is more than just optimism. This is more than just a little bit of inspiration.
We have a living hope, and his name is Jesus.
So let's return back to where we begin.
Wherever you are in your journey.
You're questioning, weary or energized.
Know that Jesus is near.
The risen Christ invites you into a relationship with himself.
The hope that he gives is a hope that lasts forever because he lives and reigns forever more.
So let's join together in celebrating and declaring that the Lord is risen indeed.
We're going to come to him in prayer now. Let me pray.
But then as I finish in prayer, just continue in prayer to the Lord where you're at.
Wherever you're at, come to him.
God, we want to praise you that Jesus came into this world, that he died to bring us back to you.
He is risen from the dead. He reconciles us with yourself.
Lord, we thank you that through the presence of the Spirit, he is here even now.
Lord, I pray that even in this moment that we would each come to you by faith, hearing you calling us to yourself.
Help us to know that you're near and to come to you in faith.
And know the hope that is found in you and in you alone as we surrender ourselves to you.
Our glorious risen King.
Amen.